[MUSIC PLAYING]
AVNISH MIDUTHURI: Good
evening, everyone.
Welcome, and hope you're having
a great time at Google IO go.
So far I'm Avnish
Miduthuri, and I'm
a product manager at
Google working on Google
Pay for online payments.
TONY CHEN: And I'm Tony Chen,
software engineer also working
on Google Pay.
AVNISH MIDUTHURI: And we're
here today to talk to you
about what we've been
working on on Google Pay
to improve online checkout.
So I'm sure a lot of
you here are already
excited about the potential
for e-commerce, and rightly so.
In the US alone in 2017,
we saw retail sales
near half a trillion dollars,
with the highest year
on year growth in
the last six years.
And we're seeing similar
growth trends globally.
But this growth is
happening despite the fact
that online conversions
haven't really improved.
From all the
estimates we've seen,
conversions across
desktop and mobile devices
has been largely flat over
the last couple of years.
And it's not hard
to see that cart
abandonment during checkout
is one of the leading causes.
When users go to
check out online,
they see long checkout forms, 15
plus form fields and other card
information, their billing
address, their shipping
address, logins, passwords,
and the list goes on.
When users see all these
forms, it's not surprising
that they drop off,
especially when
they're on a low speed data
connection on mobile devices.
So we think there's a
huge opportunity here
to really improve
online checkout.
And that's what we hope
to do with Google Pay.
At the start of this year,
we unified our payment
and checkout experiences
across all of Google
under a single
brand, Google Pay.
Our vision for Google Pay is
to enable users everywhere
to pay with their Google account
anywhere they're signed in.
So Google Pay is more than
just an app on a device
or a button on a website.
We're building it as a platform,
integrated as a core part
of our users' Google account
and available to them everywhere
they're signed into Google.
In, this session
we'll spend some time
to share some of the changes
we've made over the last year
as we've launched Google
Pay, and then we'll
talk about how you can
implement the Google Pay API.
And finally, we'll
also share some
of the product announcements
that are coming up.
So looking back a few years
ago, we launched Android Pay,
and we started our
journey with the enabling
easy in-app payments
using cards that users
has provisioned on their
device in the Android Pay app.
We launched this
feature in 112 countries
and saw great adoption from
thousands of developers.
But we heard from
you, our developers,
that you wanted more.
You wanted access to many more
users paying what more payment
methods, and in
several more countries.
And so we went back
to the strengths
of Google, our billions of
users across multiple popular
products around the world.
Our users have saved
hundreds of millions of cards
to their Google accounts,
making purchases
on apps like the Play Store,
YouTube, or even to shopping
the web using Chrome.
What Google Pay,
users can easily
make payments what the
payment methods stored
in their Google account
anywhere they're signed in,
a consistent and seamless
payment experience.
And Google Pay is already the
way users pay across Google.
Users see Google Pay
today when they check out
on the Play Store buying
an app, renting a movie,
or just on Chrome auto
filling a checkout form.
And not only is
Google Pay present
when users buy from
Google, but it's also
being incorporated into several
new surfaces for transactions
that users can make with
third party merchants.
For instance, you'll see
Google Pay powerinf checkout
for merchant experiences
within Android messages
from merchants that
have used rich business
messaging, and also a system
to enable transactions
like the Google Assistant,
or on web actions including
AMP pages.
And in keeping with
our vision, we've
extended our Google APIs
to external developers
so users can pay with all their
cards in their Google account
when they're on
your sites or apps
without any additional setup or
having to download a new app.
We launched earlier this
year with payments enabled
on Android devices,
both native apps
and on the mobile web using
Chrome's implementation
of the Payment Request standard.
In the last few
months, we've already
seen great adoption from several
developers around the world.
Take a look.
Users can already use Google
Pay on a range of merchants
from order ahead apps to retail
sites, travel, transportation,
ride sharing, and many more.
We have merchants
live across the world
from the US, Brazil, Russia,
the UK, Australia, Japan,
and many more.
And merchants with
a global user base
can enable Google Pay
for all their users
with a single API integration.
For instance, Deliveroo,
a leading order ahead app,
launched Google Pay for their
users in over 12 markets.
And Uber is rolling out Google
Pay for all of their users
globally.
And our early developers
have seen great results
from their integrations.
For example, Hotel Tonight saw
that Google Pay users converted
at a 65% higher rate than users
on their regular checkout flow,
thanks to the easy
payment experience.
And as I mentioned earlier,
our new Google Pay APIs
enable many more users to
pay with all of their cards
in the Google account.
And so when StubHub
updated from Android Pay,
they saw a 7x increase in
the number of unique users
paying with Google Pay.
And when Airbnb updated,
they saw an 11x increase
in daily transactions
from Google Pay.
And our APIs also
enable merchants
to build streamlined onboarding
experience of for their users.
For example, new Airbnb users,
when they set up the app,
can completely skip the
payment method setup flow
and complete a booking
with Google Pay
without ever having to enter any
payment information or billing
addresses.
We're now taking a
huge step to make
Google Pay available
to many more users
and to developers on the web.
Last week, we announced
that Google Pay is now
available across the web
from Android to desktop,
and yes, even on iOS devices.
Through one integration with
our JavaScript libraries,
merchants can enable
Google Pay globally,
available to all of
your users regardless
of what device or browser
they're shopping on.
We've also focused on making our
APIs really easy to integrate,
and we've been really encouraged
by the positive feedback we've
seen from developers.
For instance, The Iconic,
an online fashion retailer
in Australia,
reported that it took
just one of their developers
a week to enable and launch
Google Pay.
And in keeping with our
mission to make integration
as simple as
possible, we've also
partnered with leading
e-commerce platforms
to make accepting Google
Pay on the web even simpler.
For instance, if you're
a Shopify merchant,
all you have to do is go
to your merchant settings
page in the payment provider
section and with a single click
you can enable Google Pay.
And Shopify launched just a
few weeks ago, and in that time
we've already seen Tens
of thousands of merchants
enable Google Pay.
And finally, we've partnered
with several leading payment
providers, gateways,
and processors
around the world to
enhance security and make
it easy for their merchants
to add Google Pay.
These providers
have already enabled
Google Pay in their SDKs
and merchant solutions,
and we have many
more coming soon.
To show you now how Google
Pay works on the web
and how you can integrate
the Google Pay APIs,
I'm going to hand
it over to Tony.
TONY CHEN: Thank you, Avnish.
Can you switch to
my iPHone, please?
So I can't really walk
very far with this.
So I'm going to quickly walk
you through what the web
experience is going to be like.
I'm on a merchant
side right now.
I'm going to buy something
and check out with Google Pay.
Now as you all know,
Mother's Day is coming on up
and I haven't bought
anything from my mom yet.
As a father of two,
I normally would
try to buy something
for my wife first,
but every time I try to
pick out clothes for her,
somehow they always end
up getting returned.
So I think my mom
would appreciate
this nice green sweater.
So I'm going to go ahead
and add it to the cart.
I'm going to click
checkout, and up pops a Buy
with Google Pay button.
I'm going to open this, and
this shows our payments sheet.
Our payments sheet is what
shows the available cards
and shipping
addresses associated
with a particular
Google account.
If you happen to be logged in
into more than one account,
you can easily
toggle it like so.
And as you can see,
this is a test account,
so there aren't
any cards set up.
I'm going to go ahead
and switch it back
s I can easily check out.
Now I'm going to
ship this to my mom
so I need to add her
shipping address.
And sometimes I really
have a tough time
remembering exactly what my
mom's shipping address is.
But it's a good
thing that Google Pay
shows autofill suggestions
from the Google Maps API
to make even filling out
this form super simple.
Now that I'm done,
I'm just going
to go ahead and click
the Continue button.
And now we've just
made a purchase.
So Google Pay also remembers the
last selected card and shipping
address to make your
next checkout easier.
For example, if I open up
to the payment sheet again,
you'll now see that my
mom's shipping address
is now the default. Users will
see the same consistent user
experience across
all major browser
platforms such as Safari,
Firefox, and coming soon,
Microsoft Edge.
One other thing to note is
that this merchant page,
even though we built
this just for I/O,
we're going to actually
release this to the public
and to all of you developers
so that you can play around
with our APIs without
first having to integrate.
We built this nifty
little developer console
on the top right.
I don't know if you noticed,
but there was a little bug
little icon.
And you can easily
manipulate the request.
So for example, if I
wanted to not collect
shipping address
for whatever reason,
I can change it to false.
And if I, for some reason can't
support all the available card
networks, I'll easily
remove one like so.
And then I'm going to click
on the Google Pay button.
And now you'll see that
the shipping address is
no longer available, and my
previously selected Visa card
is no longer accepted.
Can you switch back
to the slides, please?
So for that site that you
just saw, go to g.copay/demo.
Now that we've walked through
what the web experience is
like, let me walk you through
how easy it is to integrate
with the Google Pay API.
With these four
simple steps, you
can enable the same
payment experience
that I just showed you
for all Google users.
The four steps are as follows.
You're going to download
some JavaScript,
check if the user's on
a supported browser,
add the Google Pay
button, and then open up
our payments sheet.
So first things first.
You're going to add the
script tag to your site.
As soon as the script
is loaded, you're
going to construct a payments
client object by passing
in an environment field.
We support two environment
fields, test and production.
In environment test you don't
have to register with us.
You can actually play
around with the APIs
yourself and integrate
into your site.
In environment test, we do
show the users real data.
However, whenever
they make a selection,
we actually return
you a fake token.
If you're integrating with one
of our supported processors,
we'll actually return your token
that you can actually charge
in their test environment.
Once you complete
the integration
and you're ready to
handle real payment,
come register with us through
our self-service portal,
and then flip the
environment to production.
So now that you have the
payments client constructed,
the first API you're going
to call is IsReadytoPay.
IsReadytoPay returns
a simple Boolean
telling you whether their
user is on a supported browser
or not.
At Google, we really focus
on optimizing for conversion.
So rather than you showing
yet another payment option,
you should only show
Google Pay if you
think it will help improve
your checkout experience.
So if IsReadytoPay
returns false,
don't render the
Google Pay button.
In the near future, we're
going to make an enhancement
to the IsReadytoPay
API so you can
ask for ready to pay Google
users with an existing payment
method.
Now that you know
that the user's
ready for making
a payment, you're
going to call our second
API, Create Button.
Create Button returns
a simple HTML element
that you can append to
the Dom of your site.
We highly recommend that
you should call this API
over constructing your own
button with static assets
so you can take advantage
of all of the improvements
that we make to the
button over time.
For example, in the
near future, we're
going to automatically translate
the button to the user's locale
in order to improve
click-through rates.
Another thing that
we recommend is
that you should use our
default color, which is black.
However, if you happen to
have a site with a dark theme,
we provide an alternate
white color that you can use.
The minimum that you need to
pass through this Create Button
API is this On Click
Event listener function.
So once you add the
button to your site,
the user clicks on
the button, you're
going to call or load payment
data to actually open up
the payments sheet.
The first thing
you're going to do
is construct this payment
data request object,
which is just a set of
payments configuration used
for this particular transaction.
For example, if you need
to collect a full billing
address because you
want to do an AVS check,
or to collect a phone number so
that you can contact the user,
you can easily
configure it like so.
We highly recommend
that you collect
as little information as
necessary from the user,
as we've seen
conversion rates tend
to drop whenever
you ask the user
for additional information.
One other thing to call
out in this request object
is this payment method
tokenization parameters.
This object may
have a long name,
but all it is is a set of key
value pairs that were going
to forward to your processor.
So be sure to check your
processor's integration
guidelines to find out
what they need from us.
Now that you've constructed
the request object,
you're going to pass it
to load payment data.
That's going to open
up our payment sheet.
The user is going
to make a selection.
And we're going to return to
you a payment data object.
The payment data object consists
of metadata about the user's
selection so that you can
use it to render the order
confirmation screen.
Also within the
payment data object
is this payment method token.
The payment method
token is what you're
going to actually use to
complete the transaction
by passing it to the processor.
One thing to note is
that security is already
baked into our product.
Our payments sheet
is always open
within a separate pop-up
window to eliminate
user click jacking or any
other security vulnerabilities.
What that means is if the site
happens to be compromised,
no malicious content can be
overlaid onto our payment
sheet, so it won't confuse the
user by obscuring their data.
And what that means is
a Google user's data
is always kept in their control.
So what that means for
you as a developer is
that when the click
event happens,
you must call load payment
data synchronously.
Don't make network
requests to the server
or any other asynchronous
calls in order
to avoid having the
pop-up window blocked
by the user's browser.
And that's our
entire integration.
So it's super simple.
I'm going to prove
to you how simple it
is by doing a live
implementation from scratch.
And all I'm going
to do is basically
copy and paste from the deck
I've already presented you
to show the entire integration.
Can we switch to my
Pixelbook, please?
So remember, folks, this
is a live implementation.
There is a possibility
that things may not work.
Just in case, I have this cheat
sheet that may help me out.
But hopefully, I won't need it.
All right.
So I'm going to do
this implementation
on JS Fiddle, which allows me
to enter JavaScript on the fly,
and then it'll print
out onto this result
page on the bottom right here.
So on the left we have HTML,
JavaScript's in the middle,
and CSS is on the right.
As you can see, we've
already downloaded
the script tag for p.js.
And we've already constructed
the payments client
with environment test.
So I'm just going to
expand the JavaScript
section a little bit just so
that you have more room to see.
And the first thing we're going
to do is call IsReadytoPay.
So IsReadytoPay returns
a simple Boolean
that tells you whether the user
is on supported browser or not.
So I'm going to print out
the response of IsReadytoPay.
Response.result. I'm
going to update the site.
It's taking a little
time to think about it
and try it again.
Wow.
This is art.
Let me try that.
What?
Aahh.
Thank you.
I changed this based on
someone else's suggestion,
and now that totally
screwed me up.
Thank you for catching that.
All right.
Let's print that out again.
Run it again.
Great.
The result shows you that
we're on a supported browser.
The next thing we're going
to do is call Create Button.
So Create Button returns
a simple HTML element
that we're going to use
to embed into our site.
So I'm going append the
button into the site
and then need to fill in this
Click Event Listener function,
which I'll leave blank for now.
Updates again.
And here we go.
Here's our black
Google Pay button.
Now by default, as I mentioned,
we always use the black color.
However, if your site
happens to have a dark theme,
you can easily change the
bun color to white like so.
And then you automatically
get this white button.
If you're [INAUDIBLE] to
developing on a responsive
page, or if you just
don't have real estate
and you need a
narrower button, you
can easily change the
button type to short
to get a shorter button.
And as I mentioned
earlier, you don't need
to fill in any of this at all.
By default we will always
use the black button
and the standard size.
So now we're going to call Load
Payment Data by constructing
this payment data request.
So I'm going to copy the request
object from these two slides,
and then I'm going to
merge them together.
And then we're going
to call Load Payment
Data on the button click
event, which I left empty.
And then to show that everything
is wired together properly,
I'm going to fill in this
process payment function.
So the process
payment function is
going to take in
our payment method
token, and the token
itself is a JSON object.
So I'm going to call
JSON.stringify so
that you can see the content.
All right.
Here we go.
Button click.
Going to wait a little bit.
Click on the button.
Up pops the payment sheet.
You make a selection.
This always seems to happen.
I'll do it again.
It's going to work
the second time.
Here we go.
And here is the exact
token onto the result pane.
Thank you.
Can we switch back
to slides, please?
Thank you.
So like I said, super simple.
You can complete the
entire implementation
within a matter of minutes.
Wrong button.
So I've just shared
with you what
we've been working on
the past few months
leading up until this launch.
Now I'm going to share with you
a couple of things that we're
going to be launching
soon to enhance
our offering for both users
and for you, the developer.
Let's start with the
user experience first.
As I mentioned before,
we want to have
the same consistent
payment experience
for all major browser platforms.
However, we're going to try
and optimize wherever we can.
So for the browsers that
support native UI such as Chrome
with Payment Request, we can
offer this nice native payment
sheet experience
on mobile websites.
Similar to a pop-up
window, this native sheet
is impossible to click jack
because the sheet itself
is completely separated and
detached from the Chrome app
itself.
But unlike a pop-up
window, this payment sheet
is a streamlined
purchase experience
because it allows
the user to stay
in context of the
payment within your site.
Soon we're going to be
expanding native support
from mobile onto the desktop
with the Payment Handler spec.
So Payment Handler works by
installing a service workers
into the user's browser.
A service worker is just
a JavaScript interface
between our payments sheet and
the native UI in the browser.
You don't really have to
understand what a service
worker is, nor do you really
have to understand what Payment
Handler does, because when you
integrate with the Google Pay
API, all this will
happen automatically.
We're going to do all the
heavy lifting for you.
So let me walk you
through a quick preview
of what that's going to
look like on Chrome desktop.
Can you switch me to
my Pixelbook, please?
So as you can see, we're
on our merchant page again.
This time, when I click
on the Google Pay button,
up pops our payment sheet within
this nice, secure native frame.
Very similar to the
mobile experience,
you cannot click jack this.
Also, because it's embedded
nicely into the pop-up window,
you can tell that it's
part of the same sheet.
It's native and secure.
It's not part of the
website because you
can see that the native
sheet itself is overlaid
right on top of my toolbars.
So I'm going to click Continue
just to show you that it works.
And there we go.
We just completed a payment
with Payment Handler.
Let's switch back to
the slides, please.
So as you can see, we're going
to always look for new ways
to improve our
payment experience.
Now for developers, this
Payment Handler example
is a great way to showcase
what our mantra is,
which is we want to ensure
that you only have to integrate
with the Google Pay API once.
And after that, you're going to
be able to continuously benefit
from all the
improvements that we
make without you
having to change
any parts of your integration.
When you integrate on
Android, for example,
we can make updates through
the Google Play services
to the two billion
active Android devices.
However, this has always
limited us to client releases.
Now that we've
launched on the web
and we've switched to
this new JSON interface,
we're able to take advantage
of the continuous server
pushes so that we can bring
new features and improvements
on a daily basis.
And as we look to expand Google
Pay to additional surfaces,
we want to bring the same
consistent, unified integration
experience for all developers.
So I'm happy to
announce that we're
going to be extending
the same JSON interface
and bringing it from the
web to Android, AMP, Actions
on Google, and more.
So let me walk you through
a couple of these examples
by starting with
accelerated mobile pages.
Now we've seen tremendous
adoption of AMP
from around the world.
AMP by Design is
a restricted set
of HTML with limited
JavaScript support.
By working closely
with the AMP team,
you'll soon be able to
enable Google Pay by using
the standard AMP components.
All you need to do is drop
in the same JSON payload
as you would to
load payment data,
and you'll be able to
easily render a Google Pay
button within your AMP page.
The button itself
will automatically
handle opening the payment sheet
and returning you the payment
method token.
And as we all know, payments
is no longer limited
to just websites
and native apps.
If you happen to be
collecting payments
through Android Messages or
through the Google Assistant,
you'll soon be able to also
enable the same Google Pay
experience with the
same JSON interface.
Consistent and easy to
integrate on all surfaces,
we're making Google Pay as easy
to integrate everywhere as it
is for users to pay everywhere.
Now if you're interested
in learning more about how
to collect payments
on Android Messages
or through the
Google Assistant, go
find my buddy Sean, who will be
at the Google Assistant Sandbox
from 12 to two tomorrow.
All right, Avnish.
Take us home.
AVNISH MIDUTHURI: All right.
Thank you, Tony.
So we shared a lot
of details with you
today about how you can add
Google Pay to your site,
improve conversion.
We're really excited to
see how you'll integrate.
We know there's a lot of
information out there,
and it's nicely organized
into two websites there.
There's one so you can learn
about how Google Pay can
improve things for
your business overall,
so that's g.co/pay/business.
And if you're ready
to start integrating,
just dive right into our
developer docs there.
Tony and I are also
going to be available
right after the
session in our sandbox.
That's located at Dome G. So
please stop by, ask questions.
We'll also have members
from the Google Pay
team available tomorrow if
you can't make it today.
So stop by, ask questions,
try a few demos out.
Also, if you want to learn
more about Google Pay,
we also have two more
sessions tomorrow.
The first is led by
our Payments UX team,
and it walks through
design principles,
how you can optimize
conversion using Google Pay.
And for learning about how
you can enable transactions
via the Assistant,
check out the session
on adding transactional
capabilities to your actions
tomorrow afternoon.
That's hosted by
our Assistant team.
Finally, we have a hackathon
coming up next month for those
of you on the West Coast.
It's in San Francisco.
It's in June.
So you can sign up at the
link there, or stop by, again,
at our sandbox if you
want more information.
We host developer
events globally.
So if you'd like to
see an event near you,
or if you want to stay
tuned for upcoming events,
you can sign up for our
developer documentation
and we'll keep you posted.
And that's it.
Thank you so much for attending.
Enjoy the rest of Google I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]